what were you doing the first six months
before you were accepted into the TV
writing program
I was working on my baking business I
had developed a a brochure of all like
the different types of special things
that I could do and I was gonna go out
to some wedding fairs and try to drum up
business doing favors for weddings and I
was in fact at the kitchen baking all
day to go to a food show came home and
got the email saying congratulations
you're a semi-finalist for the CBS
writers program please call and schedule
your personal interview
so it was really like a crazy what the
universe was like she's too good at the
cookie thing we gotta we gotta pivot
back and put her where she belongs
and so you rented a kitchen because
that's how you could get it sort of
permitted to to yeah yeah was um long
before there was any thought of you know
allowing people in L.A County to bake
from home or cook from home to sell it
and so
um you know Pasadena has its own
licensing requirements and all that so I
had to do all the research to figure all
that stuff out had to figure out how to
get the right insurance I mean it was a
lot but uh you know I toughed it out and
figured it out and got my business up
and running and then
Hollywood was like no change of plans
how many TV show scripts and Pilots had
you written before you were hired
oh goodness I think I have this
officially written down somewhere I want
to say that I had written 12 specs
and I had
four Pilots
and the last spec I wrote was for Person
of Interest and I finished it a few
weeks before I got my first TV writing
job so it turned out to be the last one
I ever had to write
and how long like how many pages are
let's say a normal spec most specs you
want to I mean most TV scripts in
general especially back then range
anywhere from 52 to 60 Pages you really
want to try not to go over 60 because
it's a big ask on the reading time
nowadays if you're on staff some shows
come in much shorter our scripts on
swatter 46 pages so you have to be
really you know very specific about the
word choice you can get it all in but
also keep it to a minimum
um but yeah so anywhere from like 52 if
it's a drama script if it's a comedy
script it's usually right around 30-ish
pages
what key factors uh played a part in you
being hired
I think one of the big ones was my life
experience so I broke into television
working in cop shows and I had put
myself through my undergraduate years
working as a police dispatcher and I
would work graveyard shifts and then I
would get off at 7 45 in the morning
drive to school go to school all day
come home and sleep go back to work and
thankfully I was allowed to do homework
at my desk when nothing was happening so
that's the only way I got through it
and that experience was always appealing
to people who make those kind of shows
and broadcast television as we know
those shows are very prevalent and you
know I could talk about things that were
real and that pertain to those stories
and so that was a big calling card for
me was being able to to bring that real
life professional experience in
um it was also important that I was a
black woman that I could speak to
matters of you know inequity for our
characters that we were writing that I
could talk about what it's like to be a
black woman who's the only black
employee in a play you know that I could
talk about those things and I was
willing to share those stories in the
room
um and then you know that I was prepared
that I had
written and written and written and
written and had built my muscle to the
point that someone was like okay she's
ready to do at least the basic part of
this job
because you will only get stronger and
get better as you continue your career
but you have to there's there's such a
line between
writing a decent script and writing a
professional script and it's really
about the the passion and the fluidity
that you can put on the page that it
starts to feel a little cinematic that
they can picture it when they read it
and it's not just you know she walks to
the door it's like you know she walks to
the door and it dwarfs her and it's like
you're conveying a real image with it so
you learn all that by writing and by
sharing your work with other writers
the biggest mistake that I think newer
writers make is wanting to hold other
scripts really close and not let other
people read them but you only get better
when other people read it and say to you
you know I love this idea and this
character is great I got a little
confused through here because I wasn't
quite sure why the character was doing
this or why we went to this place
suddenly and you take those notes and
you go back and make it better
because that is TV writing that is the
rest of your life if you want to write
TV as people will give you notes you
will go make changes you will turn it
back in even if you're the showrunner
the studio and the network get to give
you notes so you will take their notes
you will you know unless you're one of
those writers who declares you never
take notes uh but I do not know many of
those you know that existed yeah okay
yes yes there are there are some of them
and I'm like okay you do you but uh I
take I you know I take good notes I take
good notes sometimes there are good
notes
what do you think is more common for a
new writer in a TV room to want to hold
back some of their work or want to hold
back their personal experience and maybe
not speak to what their life was because
they don't want to offend other people
in the room or make them uncomfortable
yeah I think that they're kind of part
and parcel of the same thing I think new
writers in our writer's room have to
learn that balance of when do I speak
when do I not speak and some of it's
just literally the timing of it right
figuring out your window to say the
thing you want to say how to do it
without cutting off another writer how
to do it without crapping on somebody
else's pitch even if you don't like it
right but to be able to be like hey that
might work also what if we did Bloody
blah so that you're not you know
sideswiping them you're just saying
here's another idea and internally
you're like because I don't like that
idea
or you're being additive or you're
inspired by what someone said and you're
like oh my God I love that also could we
add this to it and then maybe it gets
better or maybe your suggestion gets
pushed to the side but you made your
suggestion and a lot of new writers are
very intimidated when they get to the
writer's room and it's a lot especially
if you are say on a broadcast show with
like 10 other writers
I'd estimate eight of those writers are
pretty solidly experienced and so it's
just Fast and Furious of story pitches
and this and that and what if we did
this and great let's have the character
move here and let's use this setting and
it starts to be overwhelming and so
the advice that I was given that I pass
on to all new writers is try to say
something you think is a value in the
morning and something of value after
lunch
in the beginning that's all anybody's
going to expect of you in fact they will
be real impressed that they got those
two things because you're a staff writer
and those people all understand that
they all know this is new to you they
all know you're trying to find your
footing
so you don't have to come in and sit
there in silence unless you have a
showrunner who's told you that the staff
writers are not supposed to speak and it
does happen but in most rooms you're so
scared to speak that that's why you're
not speaking and so you need to find
your voice and speak you also need to be
careful not to try to dominate the
conversation and take over you need to
pick up on the social cues of when the
showrunner's like yeah I don't I don't
know about that and stop talking and let
someone else pitch something you may
come back to your idea but if you keep
pushing it's going to cause some
friction in the room so it's it's really
learning that is is the first several
weeks for any staff writer is trying to
figure out how this all works and when
do I speak and when do I pull back I'm a
big proponent of having a notebook in
front of you
because as you have an idea you can
write it down
and if someone else is still talking a
you won't forget it and B because you
have it writing down you're not panicked
about getting it out and if someone else
pitches the same idea before you do at
least you can take comfort in the fact
that you were on the right track
but it's also a lesson in right your
idea was right so you can pitch it it's
fine and take the chance and Pitch it
in terms of the personal stories I think
good writers rooms Foster an environment
where writers feel safe to share their
stories
and by good writers rooms I mean safe
writers rooms places where the
showrunner has said up front
this is not a place where we bully each
other this is not a place where I'm
going to tolerate that kind of behavior
everybody's opinion here matters at the
end of the day I'm going to decide what
we're doing
so you don't even need to fight about it
because it's so to me and that allows
people to feel safe saying you know I
did have this experience when I was a
kid where like I got lost for a day and
my parents like because that's a
vulnerable thing to talk about right but
it may help the story
and you want your writers to feel safe
to help build the best story
toxic rooms
rooms where Shore Runners yell and
scream at each other nobody in that room
is giving their best nobody is telling
their best stories because they don't
feel safe
and so to respond to that kind of
behavior everybody pulls back a little
bit and it's and you should because you
need to protect yourself in that
environment